hello and welcome back to seize these
worlds today we're gonna be taking a
look at the new pre-roll ad okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry I had to people are
losing their minds right now over this
YouTube pre-roll ad for the none I
assume you've probably seen it if you're
watching this video but if not it looks
like this
and this was brought to my attention by
a tweets going viral right now by a user
named Apple who says warning if you see
an ad on YouTube with the volume sign
being turned down and nothing else
it's a jump-scare for the new none movie
coming out I advise you to look away
and/or turn down the volume if you have
anxiety or just straight-up dislike a
jump-scares please retweet to save a
life and that tweet has amassed over
100,000 retweets in just 24 hours there
are articles being written about this
and people are actually calling for
YouTube to take it down the ad to which
I have to say Apple and whoever else is
tweeting about this right now why you
got to go and ruin the fun for everyone
like me who hasn't seen the ad yet and
would have enjoyed that little scare I
mean people are acting like this is
something like the public needs to be
aware of it's not like the nun comes out
of your screen and punches you in the
face it's a loud noise not a safety
hazard
and don't you dare call for this ad to
be taken down we just got through the ad
pocalypse and it's hard enough for
horror creators like myself to earn a
living because of many brands no longer
consider horror content to be safe to
advertise on so we finally have an ad
that is tailor-made to run in front of
horror channels and you are not going to
take that away from us just so that you
don't get startled for two seconds not
to mention that as long as you have ad
personalization turned on in your Google
settings which I mean why would you not
I mean if you have to see ads you might
as well see ones that are relevant to
your interest but if you have this on
and you don't like horror movies you
probably won't see the ad anyways my ads
are personalized to include horror and I
still haven't seen this come up and to
be honest as much as I love the concept
of this ad and it reminds me of the
classic YouTube screamer videos from the
mid-2000s that you never really see
anymore this one's not really fooling
anybody I mean first of all it uses the
Mac OS volume icon and I don't know
maybe there's a different version of the
ad for Android or Windows but unless
you're on Mac and you're browsing full
screen so that the icon is actually
centered on screen you're probably not
going to fall for it but just look at
some of these responses they need to
display a warning before such ads I
cannot stand watching or even listening
to anything related to the horror genre
my heart's too fragile to take it and my
mind F's up bad and ends up haunting me
for the rest of my life well no if you
put a warning that completely ruins it
I mean the point of the ad is to catch
you off guard and get your
it's marketing 101 I watch to mute it
and I'm still on the verge of tears are
we really that soft now that people are
in tears over a six-second advert I mean
I'm so sick of everything being watered
down for my spineless excuse of a
generation everything is constantly
complained about to the point that those
of us with common sense can't have nice
things
because Therese here cannot handle the
sight of a fictional character great I'm
already having anxiety from knowing this
exists YouTube would you please revise
this ad it really isn't costumer
friendly well actually the none costume
is very well done in my opinion the
costumers did a great job but if you
feel like this ad is giving you too much
anxiety I'd recommend you crawl back
into the womb from which you came from
because you're not quite ready for the
real world yet I won't be watching
YouTube videos for a loyal then I jump
scares
this is actually interesting because
usually when someone says they dislike
jump scares it's because it movie relies
on jump scares too much and doesn't
build that suspense that you need for a
jump scare to have a good payoff
personally I really like jump scares
when they're done well and in the
context of this ad it uses the volume
icon to throw off the viewer so if the
prerequisites of being on a Mac and
being full screen are met I think it's a
clever advert but it is a bit random
theming wise like what do computers have
to do with the Romanian none demon it
would have actually fit better for a
horror movie about technology like
unfriended or friend requests or scary
friend internet movie and it looks like
before I even had a chance to finish up
this video and post it YouTube has
already gone ahead and taken down the ad
and they do point to this article on
their ad policy where they do have rules
against violent and shocking ads and
content including promotions that are
likely to shock or scare but then they
say what they consider to be shocking
factors and ads is whether the video
shows scenes containing violent and a
graphic imagery that can be shocking
either serving to viewers whether the
video shows a graphic aftermath of a
violent act whether the shots of
violence or in Gore or the focal point
of the scene in the video and whether
the violence contained in the video is
realistic when posted in dramatic
context and they also go on to say that
other factors include the camera angle
and focus and clarity of the images in
the video so it looks like this Nomad
doesn't technically have any of these
factors that they consider to be
shocking but I'm sure we'll never hear a
statement on it and my advertiser
revenue will go down as a result of this
so
perfect opportunity for me to say to
check out my merch store and maybe pick
up an item or two to support the channel
but if you are one of those people whose
life was not ruined by this ad then drop
me a like on this video I'm genuinely
curious to see what the like to dislike
ratio comes out to be on this one and
remember to subscribe to Suzy's world
for more great horror content every week
bring that death Bell for notifications
you know what ring that Bell loud enough
to startle some complainer on the
Internet and I'll see you in the next
one
assuming we both survive